Okay,
be back live here.
I've been debugging driving sim stuff
for uh the past several hours. So,
that's where I've been.
We're going to try to do um a little bit
of drone work now.
Now, we've had lots of different types
of models. It's kind of interesting that
these ones behave like this.
It's probably that these tasks are like
semiconlicting.
I don't think the drone the drone racing
task works amazingly on its own either.
There.
I have here.
Do
we're going to do task
task race.
So,
we're going to do it unrandomized.
This will give us our benchmark and
we're just going to assume that our
metrics are messed up. We're gonna have
to visually look at it.
Admittedly is not great, but uh this is
what we'll do.
I forgot I can use Neptune to pull
models.
Be much easier,
copy stuff around.
The article that I published today is
kind of good because I've been doing
kind of well over 150k views. is crazy.
Pretty interesting. I guess I should
just write more
This rings pass metric doesn't look
good, right?
Oh, B is good.
Hey, what are you doing today? I'm doing
uh drone racing debugging. Trying to
figure out why
this sim that I have I have like a good
swarming sim and a good racing sim, but
they are not working well now that I put
them together. Trying to figure out
what's going on with that.
Like the drone swarm sim was pretty much
perfect and the racing sim was pretty
much perfect.
Now it's kind of janky now that they're
both together.
I guess it's arguable. Maybe I shouldn't
have tried to even put them together. I
don't know.
We're not going to do this indefinitely
if it seems like the tasks are just
incompatible. But I think that they
should work.
That's bizarro. I guess we'll just have
to um
copy stuff manually.
Okay, so this is actually a problem.
Look at this.
See all these drones? They're like
flying around and they can't quite
figure out
how to get through the uh the target.
like almost looks to me like it's not
getting updated, right?
That doesn't make much sense.
Oh, hang on. Is this
might not be the same thing.
Might not be the same thing.
Yeah. So, let's make sure that we're
actually running the
same version.
They're definitely more agile, but they
uh they're still just stuck on this one
ring. Yeah.
Which really doesn't make any sense to
me at all.
Oh, it gets past a fixed seat, right?
Yeah, it does.
This should eventually reset to a
different course though, shouldn't it?
I just watch this for a little bit.
here. It's like they're actually kind of
doing the course a little bit more.
Right.
This is nowhere near.
They still get stuck on this ring now.
Right.
Very weird because at least some of them
are going through it. It looks to me.
Now they're just like confused like,
"Hey, what do we do?"
pretty weird.
Why would it just get stuck on a
particular ring?
Particularly with these training
settings. I understand if when you're
training on a bunch of task,
Q inverse is drone.
Okay. No, this is correct.
No, the observations are the same. This
should be totally fine, right?
when it resets
set the target for everything. Right?
There's nothing that would like in the
observations would tell it to not go
there.
Unless it's that it just can't see
closely enough, right?
worth running maybe at least while I'm
thinking about other
be very surprised if this is the
problem. Possible
Get 100k per model on.
What's up? How's it going?
How is it that it figures out how to get
to these rings so quickly,
doesn't get the next one?
like only ever getting a ring some of
the time
doing like some weird reset thing. Are
we
for drone. How confident of domain
randomization?
I think if we get it working very
cleanly in the sim with heavy domain
randomization, then it should work out.
That means uh for that to happen we have
to have the physics at least
directionally correct which should be
might be a couple other small things to
model but it should actually
condition.
Yeah, we might have to like we might
have to just add random forces during
training sometimes.
The thing is that like
you're not just guessing a sequence of
instructions, right? And saying execute
this entire sequence of instructions.
It's like it's adjusting dynamically
every step, right?
article has done like very surprisingly
well.
I thought it would get a couple hundred
at most.
Okay, so randomizing the starting
position doesn't seem to help.
kind of expected it might a little bit,
but I suppose the problem's a bit deep.
This compute reward doesn't really
matter in the current form.
Good stuff. Thank you. I will It will be
good stuff when I figure out what the
heck is wrong with this training.
Had this working quite well before.
Seem to
not a multi- drone thing. It's not a
curriculum thing.
is probably worth actually looking at
the policy to see what it does.
fact it gets up to like one ring all
perfectly.
How the heck does it does it go through
one ring just not know how to do
anything else?
really feels like it's exploiting
something, right?
going through the same ring over and
over
is kind of Yeah, it's trying to go
through the same ring a bunch of times.
Should not be getting rewarded for this.
The logs seem to indicate it's not
getting rewarded for this.
Sometimes it's doing multiple and then
it gets stuck. It's very weird.
We have GPUs that run 10,000x faster.
current GP training speed, but you don't
like my uh like two three million step
per second training. Okay.
Pathetic robotic stuff.
You got to rewrite your Sims. I don't
think your Sims are anywhere near as
fast as they could be.
See, the problem with robotics, right,
is all you guys, you went, "Okay, we got
to make a really accurate sim and then
it'll work in the real world." No, no,
no. That's not what you do. Okay? Make a
very tunable sim
that can be domain randomized to hell.
train on a ton of different permutations
so that the robot can basically work in
any sort of chaotic setting. Then you
throw it in the real world. Yeah, that
works.
Why is this thing going through it so
many times?
Is it somehow still not getting like
updated or whatever?
having vision part. Yeah.
Why you doing that?
To be fair, you can get your vision can
get your vision way faster as well. Not
puffer speed, but you can at least get
it 10x faster than it is now.
problem is nobody wants to do all the
hard engineering.
to make the pipeline.
Uh
I know uh I know a guy who's quite good
on the vision side who uh like for batch
rendering stuff done work there.
I could probably go get him if you had a
big application for it.
In the meantime, I'm working on building
out all our other tech or general
purpose RL
We'll have to do a vision like
eventually, but we can solve so much
cool stuff before we do that. You know
how much stuff we
I can't figure out how to go through a
ring.
It knows how to get to the ring and then
it's like it not triggering.
Oh no, it does know how to go through
the ring. It's just not triggering
that. That's what's happening. It's just
not triggering.
It's a little tricky because we have the
multi-agent flying one though. B.
My selfplay question. Oh jeez. Your
selfplay question I believe is a rabbit
hole.
I don't It's not You're missing context,
I'm pretty sure.
You can't link me Discord like that.
Where is it?
You paste or something.
moves too fast.
the thing that's a little annoying bet
is like we don't really have
we don't have masking in 3 0. I didn't
add it because it wasn't being used for
anything and you kind of need it for
selfplay. The best way I could figure
out how to do it. Oh, okay. You added
it. I don't know if you added it
correctly. But like the best way to do
it, right, and this is annoying because
it's inefficient.
Um, is that like
you generate the half the agents run one
step, half the agents run the next step,
but they can't go into the same episode,
right? One episode is for one agent, not
one game.
like one episode.
An episode has to be all of one agent's
moves. You can't just have like data
from both agents in one episode, right?
That's the tricky bit to it.
I'm trying to think what the best way to
hack it would be.
You know what I would probably do? Bet.
[ __ ] I have no idea how to do this
based on the current infrastructure.
Actually,
can't just alternate and board flip
though if like can't put all the data
from one agent into one episode. I mean,
we're all for one game into one episode.
You can't have the roll out for the LSTM
be agent one, agent 2, agent one, agent
two. That's not going to work.
What you'd want to do is you'd want to
hack the they get their own obs. It
doesn't matter though because the reward
function the reward function is
bootstrapped over the trajectory, right?
So, it's like it's taking into account
both agents action.
It's going to mess stuff up. At least I
think it'll mess stuff up a bunch. Yeah,
well, because you'll be bootstrapping
over the other agents rewards.
No, it doesn't need to see this position
as bad or this the thing the actual fix
for this bet for the episode data
each episode to contain one player's
data not a full game's data. Um it's
really easy if you have like a scripted
opponent because you just play your one
side.
uh you'd have to basically hack the
double buffered vectorization that we
have such that on one call to step right
you get one set of players data and on
the next call you get the next set of
players data.
You'd basically have to trick it into
thinking it has twice the number of ends
that it does.
I am going to have to help you figure
this out actually because I have people
who want selfplay uh in the environment
for sure.
It is actually kind of tricky.
Very easy to mess up as well. Oh,
rings past 33. Okay, so this was totally
the problem.
Cool.
Oh, does this not update prep pause?
I think it doesn't.
difficult time finding actual
because it's not an algorithm bet.
Like, okay, ignore chess for a second
because it's chess being turn-based and
chess being selfplay are two different
things. Okay? Every single environment
that has multiple agents in it in some
sort of cooperative or competitive
setting is selfplay. There is not an
algorithm for it. It's just a setting.
Do you see what I mean?
So the turnbased thing is not an
algorithmic difference. It's a purely an
infrastructure difference.
Except it's trickier than just double
buffering the ve because then you have
two separate environments.
I'm probably going to have to help you
with
Do you have any idea why chess is slow?
Like in my mind, chess should be very
fast.
Like literally, even if you just got a
basic chess agent that runs fast and can
play against any sort of like one look
ahead scripted bot or like some dumb
scripted bot, like that's already good.
Yeah, here we go. We fixed it. I fixed
the bug.
There's no way. Bet. Just the fact that
I know the chess engines run so fast
means that it has to be possible.
I'm pretty sure like Stockfish looks at
millions or like tens of millions of
states per second.
I will look at this with you, man. I got
to finish drones and I got to finish
some stuff, but the selfplay is on the
to-do list for sure. Have you not like
looked around on like chess is one of
the most widely implemented things ever.
Have you like looked around online and
seen if there's anything that's fast?
Like this is actually a place where you
can probably get references
What do you mean ready to train?
Yeah. No, that that's the thing. It's
going to be different, but it shouldn't
be slower. Like the fact that you have
to make it trainable is not going to
make it substantially slower.
I don't know what the hell it's doing
cuz this like thinking logic doesn't
make any bloody sense.
PhD level intelligence my ass.
It says, "Did it write a Python sim or
did it pretend to write a Python sim?"
No way it actually wrote a sim.
See, there's such a huge disconnect with
me when it's like, oh yeah, we solve IMO
gold and like even if it's like, well,
yeah, this isn't the model that solves
immo gold. Okay, but yeah, all the
models like they're a few points, right?
Okay, it should be IMO bronze or
whatever, that's still very smart. And
then anytime you actually interact with
an LLM, it's completely stupid.
This is like more reasonable, right? So
this would be hundreds of thousands.
Yeah, I think that they mean they didn't
integrate it with a proof engine, right?
But they absolutely were using it as a
benchmark internally.
Well, I'll go check the Grock output
because it'll be funny.
It would be actually pretty funny if it
act if it like wrote a valid chess sim,
but there's no way it did.
Oh, it's using it says the chess
library.
It doesn't actually show you the logic
is [ __ ] So, it probably didn't even
do it.
5.7 million.
Yeah,
we should definitely be able to do this,
man.
I think it's
10 to 50 games per second. It might have
actually run it on like a slower CPU cuz
it's not off by a huge amount.
130 games per second, 46k moves.
If your C is slower than Python,
if the test is right, that's also true.
Did we read the code? No, we didn't.
I mean, this is an actual library. It's
like maybe
random choice of legal moves. Yeah,
because it gets legal moves from the
engine, right?
It looks like it just comes from the
chest library.
We're at
almost 14.9.
very well could get 15k off of that.
That's crazy.
this is true.
Oh yeah, this is Yeah, this is godly AI.
Oh no, wait. Is it still stuck?
This definitely works. There's like some
screw up. Oh, I know what it was. I'm
just dumb. No worries.
What do we think, guys? Do we think that
this works?
Let's see if we go blame Sam and Finner.
We blame my tired ass for doing stupid
stuff. See who gets blamed for this.
Well, I don't see they delete I didn't
see them deleting it anywhere, but it
must have just been a versioning issue.
Yeah, must just be a versioning issue.
They didn't screw it up.
My bad, I guess. I must have just done a
weird merge.
Oh, you know what it probably was? Yeah,
it was probably that I never put that
version into the other file.
How do you pass the and from C to
Gymnasium? So, we don't actually use
Gymnasium for our native ends. We only
really use their spaces API, not
anything else. Um, but we have this
binding file sort of covered in the docs
and stuff a little bit.
So, this is just Python API stuff. It's
kind of obnoxious. Um, but what this
does is it instantiates a bunch of your
environments and handles passing
variables for you. You're free to read
it. The Python API is kind of gross, but
uh the point of this is
that it lets you just bind stuff like
this.
This is all you have to write. Oops.
Yeah, this is literally all you have to
write. You just basically tell it what
parameters you want to pass in and what
log variables you want to get out.
So, it makes it pretty easy.
Yeah.
I don't love the uh the code that I have
for the C uh binding file. Like you're
never going to have to read it as a
normal user. I don't love how the uh the
code is though for our end binding file,
but it's the first iteration of this.
300 is the first version where we've had
this and uh I hadn't worked with the
Python capi api before. It's kind of
gross. It's very errorprone. So it is
what it is for now. It will be improved
over time.
Kind of focused on building out more
applications at the moment though.
really showing what Puffer can do more
broadly.
I don't know what you mean by a neural
data.
Well, not everything bad. Like there are
things that you would not do in C, you
would do in CUDA, which is just C that
runs on GPU,
which is basically the same thing. This
the cool thing about this though is
like, you know, if you know C, it's not
hard at all to write some basic CUDA.
like compilation stuff is a bit of a
pain there, but the code's kind of the
same. Like CUDA is just straight up C
that runs on your GPU.
You just specify the axis of
parallelism, right? So like you write
the function that runs it for one drone
for instance, then if you have a whole
big block that has all the drones in it,
then you it runs on each drone in the
block or whatever. That's pretty much
it.
never done RL just cranking out CUDA
kernels. Honestly, if anybody here knows
like is good with CUDA dev, there are
some things that could be done in puffer
that would be very very very helpful.
I do a little bit of stuff, but would be
way better.
Why puffer user so cracked? I mean,
that's kind of the goal. There really
not that many people anymore who
actually give a [ __ ] about like learning
low-level systems and really
understanding how to build things
correctly.
Working on creating images
based on I assume that's thoughts. Some
signals are known, some are not. I want
to make the brain signals environment
for different signals to find things.
Well, I don't know if it's going to be C
or CUDA, right? But it sure ain't going
to be Python.
It's definitely not the case that as you
build more complex ends, you stop caring
about performance. It's the opposite. If
anything, the more complex the end does,
the more hardcore you have to be on the
performance engineering. Most of what we
do performance art is actually
considered very very basic low-level
system stuff. Very very basic.
Yeah, the thing is I'm new to RL and
want to do best practices
specifically. There would be a lot of
performance. Yes, of course. So, there
are no best practices in RL. In fact,
all the best practices you will find in
RL are in fact worst practices. The
field is a mess. Um, what we have is
pretty much just how to keep stuff
simple and fast and minimally
errorprone.
So you can see how we do stuff in
Puffer.
Um,
yeah, we don't do best practices stuff.
It's like that's that's kind of dogma
for the sake of dogma. We like we walk
you through how we tend to build stuff
like best practices in isolation doesn't
do much. It's way better to see like how
we build stuff in context and why we
recommend building stuff the way we do.
play neural MMO 3 as an article. I could
very well. So,
I think we're going to do neural MMO 3
as an article bet when we have like a
massive breakthrough on training. Okay.
It'll take a year to develop, but can I
do it somehow? So, you add it to Puffer?
Of course.
I'll be surprised if anything takes a
year in Puffer Lib, by the way. Like,
things move very, very quickly. I built
Neural MMO 3 in a few months and with
way way worse tools than what we have
now.
Like I could probably do neural MMO 3
now in like a month or less.
Yeah, good and useful ends get added
pretty much. And we love applications as
well. If you have like cool real world
applications or like actual science uses
for RL, we're all over that. It's
actually the thing that we're most
interested in at the moment is like
where can we use this to improve other
areas of science and do other you know
to do interesting things.
Frankly in my mind like major
contributions to science are just as if
not more valuable than like business
side development right that is my
ultimate goal with all of this. You
think I'd be doing all this the way I
was I were doing it if the sole goal
were the business side? No, man. I want
to improve science.
Love working open source. Fintech. Yeah,
fintech is rough.
money during that's no fun at all. Yeah,
rough
fintech is is like especially rough.
Envy,
we've actually found a pretty good way
to do like some finance adjacent stuff
with Puffer in a way that makes sense.
They'll release a bunch of stuff, but
yeah.
Any C tutorials you recommend, articles?
I don't read. Uh, if you've never done
NEC, you're probably going to have to at
least do some amount of a formal course.
Hey, Yaxine. How's it going?
Oh, hey, uh, Yaxine. I I guess you're
here from the uh you're probably here
from the post to be honest.
But here, we'll show you it's real.
Take a look.
Pretty zippy, right?
Java, Python, Mat Lab, and NeverC.
The course I took was Stanford's 107.
It's not a great course. It's really
boring. They're probably better ones.
You really only need the most basic
fundamentals. Plot the motors like their
thrusts.
I'm trying to think how I would do that
quickly.
We have RPMs actually now. We modified
the physics. There was a physics update.
It's hacking.
I have the code.
What do you mean it's hacking?
like it's able to just like spin way too
fast. It's totally possible that it's
like, you know, it's assuming it has
super powerful motors or there's not
enough motor lag or something.
Jittering thrust up and down.
What does Wait, what does that
accomplish?
Oh, reward hacking. Yeah. So, I had I
don't know when you pulled this. Um, for
the racing task specifically, I just
fixed a bug. Well, in the swarm version,
I I just fixed a bug where it wasn't
properly checking when it was going
through the rings. So, actually, it
wasn't hacking the reward. It was just
trying to get to the target and the
target wasn't registering.
It actually wasn't a reward hacking
thing. It was just like the environment
dynamics being wrong.
can be on stream. Yeah, he's if you want
to chat, I'm happy to do that.
Run for dis for dinner in a little bit
here, but I wanted to do a couple other
things.
I don't know if this is going to work,
but let's see if we can actually get it
to jointly learn all the tasks. This
would be pretty crazy, you know, instead
of just training on racing task, what if
we train on uh all the task, right? We
just do this. It wasn't working before,
but I mean our rewards were wrong.
If you'd have to apply it to read
drones.
Oh, to real drones. Directions.
Uh, we are going to apply this to real
drones.
Not that much to be honest. We're going
to have to just tweak a few parameters,
but we have Finn and Sam who are in the
Discord are working on getting it on a
real drone. I'm working on like cleaning
up the sim for us.
Oh yeah, Yaxine. Um, there have been
some updates to the physics you might
want that add like motor lag and um,
well, to be honest, I don't understand
all the math. I didn't fully read it,
but there were some I think linear drag
and motor th uh motor lag were the two
things courtesy of Finn and Sam.
You have motor lag. Cool.
Accelerometer noise.
They see their acceleration. I don't
even know if they get that as an
observation.
We probably will have to change stuff
cuz right now they get position, but
they're probably not going to be allowed
to get their position.
It kind of depends on what sensors we
decide to have. What about wind?
Uh, wind. We can if we just apply random
force perturbations every so often. I
think that'll do a decent enough job
with wind
just learns.
Well, you're doing something pretty
different, right? Like you don't have a
go to goal, do you?
We don't need absolute position, but we
would still need relative position to
the goal or it needs some way to know
where the goal is.
Gyro Excel. You can do that. We'll have
a goal.
But is the goal like a position? Like a
position or what?
Like there's going to need to be some
way for to understand the objective
position. Yeah. I don't know what sensor
you have that's going to do like
relative position.
If you just want hover and you have a
depth sensor, that's fine.
stability. Oh yeah, you can totally just
if you just want to do hover, you can
totally do it from that. Honestly, I
think that the biggest bottleneck is
probably your hardware at the moment.
You should probably have like a more
stable frame because that's not part of
the sim, right? The sim is it's rigid
physics.
You can print one, right?
If you don't feel like like waiting for
one to uh waiting and like buying one,
you can just print one.
It is rigid.
Is it the thing that you showed me? Cuz
I don't think that that would qualify as
rigid. I won't show it on stream.
It's funnier if it's a box.
I mean, I suppose so.
Are the motors actually strong enough to
like lift that stably?
Do you know how much thrust they can uh
output?
This seems like this kind of worked.
That was 20%. Ah, okay.
Have you considered putting some
shielding on them? because um you're
going to break a whole bunch of those,
I'm sure, in the process of
experimenting before you get it right.
The one that we got, I very
intentionally made sure had shielding.
I don't think you had it on yours that I
saw. I could be misremembering.
Safety glasses. Yes. I uh I had a uh a
boss who uh in a wood shop who lost an
eye when I was growing up. So,
you do not screw around with that stuff
at all.
Even when you think you don't need it,
it's like if you wait until you think
that you're going to need it, you're
probably too late.
Yeah. Have you gotten yourself a lab
coat yet?
That was always kind of lame to me that
like AI labs are literally just a bunch
of guys on computers.
Like nobody's got lab coats or like cool
equipment or anything.
Come on.
Whoa. Okay, this is our policy. Well,
this is the old policy actually. Hang
on.
It's a SCP.
All right. So, now we have the latest
policy.
It still is able to race. No problem
there.
doesn't quite make this fear, I don't
think.
Are they going to follow this?
They kind of follow this. Yeah.
Yeah, they do.
I think the formations thing needs work.
So, the thing is I actually don't know
if these guys can hover.
I messed with all the physics. Should
probably figure that out, right? Let's
just train at the flag task real quick.
Uh my workflow is usually a bit better
than this cuz I train on the same
machine. I happen to be on my crappy old
desktop now and I don't want to tax it
with the stream running.
So, usually it's just nice because I
have it all on the same machine
and then I like use remote machines when
I have to like launch overnight stuff.
Probably going to pick some sim to real
task
be easier.
at a certain Y position.
Ah, yeah, you could
you could do that just like stable. I
mean, that's like way easier, right?
Come on. I thought you were going to
win, right? You got to do the hard
problem.
I'll help you out with the uh the RL.
It'll be fun.
The crazy thing about this is how bad
the reward is for racing. And it still
works. It's literally sparse. It gets
one for going through the ring.
RL is fine. Stuck on the interface.
Provable given enough time.
What you mean like sending data to the
drone that like what were the existing
things like um too high latency or what?
I'm the policy control. Ah, yeah. Okay.
Like just low-level data communication
then, right?
That's legit.
I mean, if you're building your own
stuff, that's a heck of a lot easier to
control, right? Like, yeah, it's a pain
that you're going to have to figure out
the actual like, okay, how do I talk to
this thing?
How important do you think the latency
even is though, honestly? Like
I wouldn't
I wouldn't be surprised if uh we could
just build it into the sim
MS.
Wait, what do they what do they support
if not motor thrust? What's the
interface they give?
We can just change the sim to be
whatever it is that we have
hertz.
Uh I think it's 50 hertz at the Well, it
depends. We have different versions.
Sometimes it's 20 like sometimes it's 20
hertz
MPS.
What is
This gets to 857. I don't think this is
good.
Hard would it be to build? Not that
hard.
Shouldn't be.
The problem that you're going to have
with your custom stuff, right, is like
actually getting it into a a package
that's like stable and usable. I mean,
for a hobby project, you know, whatever.
But if you wanted to have like an actual
drone on that, now you have to do like
production.
So
like here, I'll show you the only
electronics project, like the only
couple electronics projects I've ever
done.
Why does my site not work?
There we go. The only electronics
projects I've ever done, I had this
glove
that used like basic ML to like
recognize gestures and then I had this
MP3 player
and that's from a decade ago.
Literally actually over a decade ago, 12
years now. Old
I like that printer prints the parts to
make itself fly.
That's cool.
Not going to work, but be funny.
the domain randomization does have its
limitations.
Do you know the story of uh the OpenAI
cube? The Rubik's cube.
I can tell that story. that's no longer
private.
So like that project at the time
that was like a marvel at the time,
right? It was so so difficult to do that
um to get like an actual hand to
manipulate a cube. And at first it was
literally just like turning it. And that
was still a marvel.
They had the problem solved in
simulation like I forget if it was nine
months or 12 months. It might have even
been eight months before they got it
working in the real world. You know,
they solved it in sim very very quickly.
But it took them just a massive massive
amount of time in randomization. I mean
they had to randomize because it was
like from camera or whatever. They had
to randomize colors of everything. Uh
they had to randomize friction. They had
to randomize like joints and stuff. They
had to randomize gravity. had to
randomize so so so many things. Like it
was very fiddly, right? Like you
couldn't move the setup to a new spot
and have it work. You like had to fiddle
with it and tune it and tune it and tune
it to get it to work in one specific
spot. And this is like very common in
robotics for stuff to be that fiddly.
So the good news for you is I think that
this becomes more relevant in
highdimensional control because like the
basic rigid body physics model you have
is actually not a terrible fit. And like
when you're randomizing that model, you
have a decent shot that your real drone
is somewhere in the training data.
Whereas when your physics model is
fundamentally inadequate, like the thing
that you care about isn't even in the
domain randomized data. A lot of the
time you have to be both trying to make
the model better and also trying to
randomize. But for Loi, you're usually
kind of okay as far as I can see.
Yeah. Okay. So, as we can see, this is
not great.
And I think that this is the domain
randomized drones. I think like they
just can't be stable.
We'll see if that's the case. If I'm
right, then I should be able to disable.
I got to go to dinner soon. I'm freaking
starving. But I want to actually have a
couple cool results first.
Plus thought out.
Walk there.
But there are limitations, right? As far
as I can tell, it's magic. RL is pretty
good.
Pretty good.
I got to get some like better models to
load in. Actual quadcopter models.
Oh well, just adding another zero to the
steps works. Yep.
This did not exist a year ago.
Like actually here, let me show you. I
think I have one of the graphs.
Let's
see if I can get my old wii
There were 16,000 experiments in here
apparently.
Oh, well that's unfortunate. I guess it
did something weird. I used to have a
curve that I could show you from Puffer
2.0. Um,
where it was like it's very crashy and
unstable before and that was already way
better than everything else out there.
It's like usually you can't just scale
stuff and have it work in RL. Things you
take for granted in the rest of AI just
do not work.
A lot of this was like stability from
the improvements in 3 0
because this article actually did really
well. That's kind of ridiculous.
I wrote this in like an hour and a half
on stream this morning.
Yeah. The thing is these notifications
don't matter as much as these
notifications which are like potential
inbound.
Hey, Garlic,
just post.
Yeah, I don't know. I guess I tend to be
more curated with my stuff. I've tried
just posting tons of stuff, actually,
and it's done worse for me.
Like my random stuff, it actually it
like loses me uh views.
My stuff is like mostly more
intentional.
What's going on here? I will show you in
just a moment.
Is there a thing where like
is there a thing that penalizes you
based on post count? Because it seems
like if you post like once or a couple
times a day, you're good. And if you
post constantly, you're also good. But
if you have somewhere in the middle,
it's not.
Me a lot just reading your code.
No, I will take your word of it given
your uh previous tenure.
Algorithm is very simple.
I actually tooured at X um last summer.
Was it Andrew or James?
You go catch up with them. I don't know.
The thing was like I kind of saw well
first of all I was already doing puffer
lib stuff right but also I saw like the
legacy code base that was inherited and
like I didn't want to deal with the
legacy code base of however many
engineers Twitter used to have.
I'm really not good at that. Like if you
put me in a big codebase, I'm not really
going to be able to do much more than
your average engineer, right? It's
really when I get to take a hard problem
and turn it into a like if I get to take
a big problem and turn it into a small
problem, that's where I'm able to do
stuff.
I'm kind of just as screwed as everyone
else once everything's a mess.
Hey, you're in the right place then.
Welcome. Yeah, something's definitely
broken here because like look at this.
Let's um Did I forget to SCP?
Maybe I forgot to pull the model. Hang
on.
Not any better.
Yeah, this really is not any better,
huh?
Let me try the hover task.
Peace. Keep it up. Thank you.
Nothing anywhere what you can do alone.
Yeah, I do think like the max impact is
either alone or like small team.
We have um yo gar garlic if you're
looking for guides on my x uh there is a
programming and ML guide as well as a
specific RL guide that people have found
quite helpful.
I would suggest either of those. I
really put a lot of thought into them.
Yeah, we've got like a whole nice
community of people doing RL.
It's really RL, not General ML. Um,
but hey, there's useful resources
regardless, right? Okay, last task
before I really am just too hungry and I
need to go get dinner.
Just I want to do the hover task real
quick.
Basically, if this doesn't get I don't
even have to eval, right? If this
doesn't get a very high score, then I
just know something is off with the
physics because it should absolutely be
able to hover. And we did change the
physics.
use AI in CLI whether
um I highly personally I highly
recommend against the very heavy
AI tools especially if you're new
especially if you're learning I use
Neoim with Super Maven and I only use it
for single line autocomplete it
basically saves me typing. I don't
really use it to like, you know, figure
out how to implement something.
The stuff that we do around here has a
it has a very a very heavy focus on like
getting closer to bare metal, like
really understanding how to optimize
things.
And like regardless of how good the
models get, even if the models can do
like get better at doing that, still
important to be able to have the
understanding.
I like models for um you know, saving me
typing and looking up docs. I don't like
them for like trying to automate
substantial portions of my job.
because I'm just robbing myself of the
experience.
Yeah. So, this just means that there's
like there's some quirks. Physics is
probably fine. Um, I will eval this for
you real quick so you can see. Get
dinner
and automate. Yeah, we'll see whether
they get better or not. Right.
It's kind of ridiculous though in my
mind that like you keep seeing these
posts like, oh, it's like bronze level,
IMO, now it's silver level, now it's
gold level, now it's solved. Like all
these things and like it can't write
coherent basic code.
And the thing is like most of the
researchers most of the researchers
using it to write their code I mean no
shame to them they're good researchers
but they're terrible programmers like
doesn't really tell you much that like
oh yeah openai researchers and
researchers and Google researchers use
these tools to write their code like
they're not good programmers they're
good researchers. Few
more so the low-level engineers though
they're
Oh, that's not good at all. Good thing I
eval it.
That's awful.
Did I get the right model? Hang on.
Must not have gotten the right No, I
didn't get the right model. Hang on.
I'm just dumb. Didn't get the right
All right. Nope. We're good. See, they
hover perfectly.
We'll be able to get these to do the
flag. No worries. I probably just messed
something small up.
Okay, I got to eat though. Man's got to
eat. Um, thank you folks for tuning in
today. Sunday is my day off, so I go get
myself a good run in, relax a bit, so on
and so forth. Uh, if you're interested
in all this stuff, I'll be back Monday.
In the meantime, start the GitHub helps
me out a lot. Free doesn't cost you
anything. Helps me out a lot.
Fallenpuffer.ai.
Want to get involved with development?
We have brand new programmers in here
that are learning and actually
contributing to useful research quite
quickly right here. Click the Discord,
discord.gg/puffer,
or you can follow me on X for more RL
content, including a bunch of
educational material, but also reports
on some of our research. Thank you
folks. And uh yeah.